howdy thick boy enthusiasts this is the  shmo and this is the debut of the shmo  we'll know we're right outside the  fighter hotel here at ufc san diego just  finished up the weigh-ins in the main  event you got marlin cheeto vera and you  have the dominator dominic cruz a lot of  people ask why is there so much beef  between the two the shmo wouldn't say  there's beef but we'd say there's high  tension high stakes you got the  dominator the inaugural ufc bantamweight  champion the three-time champion looking  to make another run at title contention  he got marlon cheeto vera the up and  comer looking to get his first taste of  ufc gold this is like a title eliminator  fight the stakes are extremely high why  if the winner of this fight here in san  diego wins in grand fashion you can make  a case they are getting a title shot  next and that's why you see what you see  the shmo out